Last weekend, I gave a talk at Chautauqua in upstate New York. Which, if you don't know what that is, starting in the 1870s, it was this high-minded lecture circuit-- like Ted Talks, but before the internet, or public radio before the invention of radio-- with a big religious component. Which is how I fell into this long conversation about the literal word of the Bible. It happened the staffer who drove me to the airport was a retired Methodist preacher, an associate pastor at one of the churches in Chautauqua, named John Jackson.
上周末，我在纽约州北部的肖托夸做了一次演讲。如果你不知道那是什么，从1870年代开始，这是一种高格调的巡回讲座——就像Ted演讲，但在互联网出现之前，或者像广播发明之前的公共广播——并且带有浓厚的宗教色彩。这就是我陷入关于《圣经》字面意思的长谈的原因。那天送我去机场的工作人员是一位退休的卫理公会牧师，他在肖托夸的一间教堂担任助理牧师，名叫约翰·杰克逊。
And we had this hour and a half long drive and somehow we got onto how he doesn't believe that every word of the Bible is literally true, which, if you're a Methodist, that's no big deal. And John said that as he gets older, the literal words of the Bible seem less important to him than the big picture. Love your neighbor as yourself, and love God above all.
我们有一个半小时的车程，不知怎么就聊到了他不相信《圣经》的每一个字都是字面意义上的真理，如果你是卫理公会教徒，这没什么大不了的。约翰说，随着年龄增长，《圣经》的字面意思对他来说似乎不如宏观大局重要。爱人如己，爱上帝超乎一切。
I told John, like, I totally get the love your neighbor as yourself part of that. Like, I can see how that can reshape just everything about how you treat others, and really, everything you do in your life in the world. But I told him I've never really understood why is it important to love God above all. Do you know what I mean? If you do what God wants, and you try to be good, you try to treat others right, what difference does it make if you love God? What does God care?
我告诉约翰，爱人如己那部分我完全理解。我能看出这如何重塑你对待他人的方式，以及你在这世上所做的一切。但我告诉他，我从未真正理解为什么要爱上帝超乎一切。你明白我的意思吗？如果你做了上帝想要的事，努力做一个好人，努力善待他人，那你是否爱上帝有什么区别吗？上帝在意吗？
And I got to ask John about kind of a variation on this question that I've wondered about for a couple years, ever since the last time I was in synagogue. I don't know. This was two or three years ago. I hadn't been to synagogue in forever.
我问了约翰一个类似的问题，这是我几年来一直想知道的，自从我上次去犹太教堂以来。我不确定，那是两三年前的事了。我已经好久没去过犹太教堂了。
And it was the anniversary of my mom's death. And we're Jews, so you're supposed to go say Kaddish, this old prayer that's one of the central prayers in Judaism at the anniversary of somebody's death. And so my dad, and my stepmom, and I were at one of the daily services that observant Jews go to every day in Baltimore where I grew up.
那天是我母亲去世的纪念日。我们是犹太人，所以按理说应该去诵读卡迪什，这是犹太教核心祈祷文之一，在某人去世周年时诵读。所以我父亲、我的继母和我参加了巴尔的摩的一场日常礼拜，我就是在那里长大的。
And I always liked going to synagogue as a kid. We went a lot. And so it was nice going back. I know all the Hebrew prayers by heart. And [LAUGHS] I don't know if this is good or bad, but not having sat in a synagogue in over a decade, it really hit me how every day is a rerun.
小时候我很喜欢去犹太教堂。我们经常去。所以回去感觉不错。我能背诵所有的希伯来语祈祷文。（笑）我不知道这是好事还是坏事，但十多年没去犹太教堂了，我确实感觉到每天的礼拜就像重播一样。
Do you know what I mean? They never do a new episode. Every day, the same words, same songs in the same order, stretching back hundreds of years. They read a new part of the Bible, part of the Torah some days. So there's that, but all the rest basically exactly the same every day.
你明白我的意思吗？他们从来没有新剧集。每天，同样的词，同样的歌，同样的顺序，延续了数百年。他们有时会读《圣经》或《托拉》的新章节。所以确实有那部分，但剩下的基本上每天都完全一样。
And everybody is singing and chanting. And I started looking at the prayer book on the side of the page with the English translation of the prayers, which I hadn't done in years. And I really was struck at how many of them-- the Amidah, the Ashrei-- are about praising God at length. That's what the words mean. Even the Kaddish, which you say over and over during services.
大家都在唱诵。我开始看祈祷书侧面的英语翻译，这是我多年没做过的事了。我真的很惊讶，其中有多少——比如阿米达祈祷文，阿什雷祈祷文——都是关于长时间赞美上帝的。这就是字面的意思。即使是你在礼拜中反复诵读的卡迪什也是如此。
[RECITING THE KADDISH IN ARAMAIC]
（用阿拉姆语背诵卡迪什）
It goes on and on. And the words basically are, "May His great name be exalted and sanctified. Blessed and praised, glorified and exalted, extolled and honored, adored and lauded be the name of the Holy One." That is what they have you say when your mom dies. Comforting, huh? It's basically God is great over and over, building up to this beautiful line, really beautiful, that's basically God is so great. It's beyond the power of any prayer, or word, or song, or praise. It's beyond the power of language to capture it.
它没完没了。这些词基本上是：“愿祂伟大的圣名被尊崇和圣化。愿那位圣者的名字被祝福、赞美、荣耀、尊崇、颂扬、尊荣、崇拜和赞颂。”这就是你母亲去世时他们让你说的话。很安慰人，对吧？它基本上就是在不停地说上帝很伟大，最终构建出这一句优美的、真正优美的短语：上帝太伟大了。它超越了任何祈祷、言语、歌曲或赞美的力量。它超越了语言所能捕捉的极限。
And it really hit me, sitting there-- what does God get out of that? Why does he want us sitting down and telling him how great he is for 45 minutes a day? Is he that needy? If some parent demanded that of their kids-- OK, I want you to praise me for 45 minutes a day, every single day of your life-- we would know they were nuts.
我坐在那里突然意识到——上帝从这些中得到了什么？他为什么想要我们每天坐在这里花45分钟告诉他他有多伟大？他有那么需要吗？如果某个家长强迫孩子这样做——好吧，我希望你们每天、你们生活中的每一天都花45分钟来赞美我——我们一定会认为他们疯了。
And it's like what I was saying to John-- what does God care if we love him? And John had such a lovely answer. He said, first off, he thinks lots of people make the mistake of picturing God as being like us, like humans. Like he's somebody who we're calling on the phone or something when we're praying.
就像我对约翰说的那样——如果上帝不在意我们是否爱他，那又怎样？约翰的回答非常精辟。他说，首先，他认为很多人犯了一个错误，把上帝描绘得像我们人类一样。就像他是我们在祈祷时打电话的对象一样。
But the way he sees it, he understands God to be all the values and principles that he sees in scripture-- the obligation to love each other, to be honest and decent in our dealings with each other, all of those things. And when he's praising God, he said that's what he's praising. He's basically re-pledging himself to those principles, which he loves. In other words, the literal words of the Bible, the literal words of the prayers aren't as important as that pledge-- a pledge to act a certain way in the world.
但在他看来，他将上帝理解为他在经文中看到的所有价值观和原则——爱彼此、在交往中诚实和得体的义务，所有这些事物。他说，当他在赞美上帝时，他实际上是在赞美这些。他基本上是在向这些原则重申他的承诺，而这些原则是他所珍视的。换句话说，《圣经》的字面意思、祈祷文的字面意思，都不如那个承诺重要——一个在世界上以某种方式行事的承诺。
And reading and calling around in the days since we had that conversation, I've learned that other clergy-- Christian, Jewish, Muslim-- some of them say the same things, especially that God doesn't need our prayers. The prayers are for us. One of them told me the Kaddish is supposed to comfort me after my mom's death by pointing me to this idea of God's presence in the world, the goodness in the world-- which, if I believed in God, I guess could be a comfort. But I don't believe.
在那次谈话后的几天里，我阅读并咨询了一些人，我了解到其他神职人员——基督教、犹太教、伊斯兰教——有些人也这么说，尤其是上帝不需要我们的祈祷。祈祷是为了我们自己。其中一人告诉我，卡迪什旨在通过引导我思考上帝在世上的存在、世间的善，来安抚母亲去世后的我——如果我信仰上帝，我想这可能是一种慰藉。但我并不信。
But weirdly, even without that, without believing any of the words, I do find it's a comfort to say the prayer. It's just-- it's familiar. It's familiar as the nursery rhymes my mom sang to me as a kid, as the Shema, the prayer that she had me and my sister say every night before we went to sleep. It's comforting.
但奇怪的是，即使没有信仰，即使不相信那些话，我确实发现诵读这段祈祷文是一种慰藉。它很熟悉。它就像我母亲小时候唱给我的童谣一样熟悉，就像《示马》一样，那是我和姐姐每天睡前都要诵读的祈祷文。它让人感到安慰。
Despite the fact that it's in another language and part of a doctrine I don't believe anymore, just the fact of it handed to me by my parents and to them by their parents-- Frida, and Lou, and Melvin, and Molly-- and their parents before them-- David, and Elizabeth, and Isidore, and people whose names I don't even know-- and before them, their parents for hundreds, and hundreds, and hundreds of years and standing in synagogue that day, standing and saying these words in unison with other mourners, it was comforting.
尽管它是一种外语，且属于一个我不再相信的教义，但它由父母传给我，由他们的父母传给他们——弗里达、卢、梅尔文和莫莉——以及他们之前的父母——大卫、伊丽莎白、伊西多尔，甚至还有我连名字都不知道的人——在他们之前，还有数百年来无数代人。那天站在犹太教堂里，与其他哀悼者齐声诵读这些话，确实令人感到安慰。
[RECITING THE KADDISH IN ARAMAIC]
（用阿拉姆语背诵卡迪什）
Today in our show, the sometimes very old words that we turn to for comfort in moments of adversity and at other times, they can be very random. The novel, Little Women, A Tribe Called Quest and other old school hip hop-- we have stories about each of those. WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，有时我们会在逆境时刻向非常古老的文字寻求慰藉，而有时它们可能非常随机。小说《小妇人》、《部落呼唤》以及其他老派嘻哈音乐——我们有关于这些的故事。这里是芝加哥WBEZ广播电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Go to the Mattresses. Shamyla always loved books. Back in 1989, like lots of other 11-year-olds, she also loved Punky Brewster and Paula Abdul. But her main thing was reading. The Baby-Sitters Club books, Little House on the Prairie-- it was all about words and books. And then something happened, which totally changed what she read, and how. Elna Baker talked to her.
第一幕，睡个好觉。沙米拉一直很喜欢书。回到1989年，像许多其他11岁的孩子一样，她也喜欢庞基·布鲁斯特和宝拉·阿巴杜。但她最喜欢的是阅读。《保姆俱乐部》系列、《大草原之家》——全是关于文字和书。然后发生了一件事，彻底改变了她的阅读内容和方式。埃尔娜·贝克采访了她。
OK, so you meet somebody at a party, and they ask you, what's your favorite book? What's your answer?
好的，如果你在派对上遇到某人，他们问你，你最喜欢的书是什么？你的回答是什么？
My answer is Little Women is my all time favorite book.
我的回答是《小妇人》是我一直以来最喜欢的书。
And then if they were to ask you, why, what would you say?
如果他们问你为什么，你会怎么说？
Well, I probably would have a very long conversation with someone about that. But it goes back to the '90s when I was living in Pakistan. And this was the only book that I had in my possession for a couple of years.
嗯，我可能会和那个人进行一场很长的谈话。但这要追溯到90年代，当时我住在巴基斯坦。那是那几年里我唯一拥有的一本书。
A couple of years when she was basically held in captivity in Pakistan. I'll tell you how she found herself holed up with only one book in a minute. But first, here's how she ended up in captivity. She was raised in suburban Maryland. Her father was an economist, her mom a teacher. She went to an all girls' prep school.
她在巴基斯坦基本上被软禁了几年。稍后我会告诉你她是如何发现自己只带了一本书被困在那里的。但首先，说说她是如何被囚禁的。她在马里兰州郊区长大。她父亲是经济学家，母亲是老师。她上的是一所全女子预科学校。
At 11, she learned her parents weren't her biological parents. Her mom, the oldest daughter in her family, couldn't have kids and really wanted to. And so Shamyla's family came up with a solution, one that's not unusual in Pakistan. Since her mom was the oldest, it was her younger sister's obligation to give her a child. And because of this family pressure and a sense of duty, the younger sister did it. But then it got complicated.
11岁时，她得知父母不是她的亲生父母。她的母亲是家中长女，无法生育，但非常想要孩子。于是沙米拉的家庭想出了一个解决方案，这在巴基斯坦并不罕见。既然母亲是长女，她的妹妹就有义务为她提供一个孩子。由于这种家庭压力和责任感，妹妹照做了。但后来情况变得复杂了。
Well, my adoptive parents had kids. They had a son. And then they had another son, and that really made my biological family confused and angry. And they were like, we gave you our child. And now you have your own children. Give us our daughter back. And my mom said, I'm not going to give her back. She's not a ball. I can't toss her back.
嗯，我的养父母有了自己的孩子。他们有了一个儿子，然后又有了另一个儿子，这让我亲生家庭感到困惑和愤怒。他们说，我们把孩子给了你们。现在你们有了自己的孩子。把女儿还给我们。我母亲说，我不会把她还给你们。她不是球。我不能把她扔回去。
For years, they fought over this. When Shamyla was 12 on a visit home to Pakistan, her birth parents asked if they could take her on a trip. Her mom agreed as a gesture of goodwill. It'd just be a week long, and she'd get to know her cousins, who were actually her brothers. And at first, it was really fun.
多年来，他们为此争执不休。沙米拉12岁时，在一次回巴基斯坦探亲期间，她的亲生父母问是否可以带她去旅行。她的母亲出于善意同意了。那只会是一个星期，她可以借此认识一下她的表亲，他们实际上是她的亲哥哥。起初，这真的很有趣。
Until I got really sick at someone's house, and it turned out I had malaria. And what I didn't realize at the time was that they had taken me there on purpose because it was way out in the country where no one could find me.
直到我在某人家里病得很重，原来我得了疟疾。我当时没有意识到的是，他们是有意带我到那里的，因为那是远离人烟的地方，没人能找到我。
Two weeks go by, then three. She's all better, asking when she can go back.
两周过去了，然后是三周。她康复了，问什么时候可以回去。
And they kept making excuses. Um, you just need to wait. We have some other places to go. And I remember at some point, my biological father taking me aside very kindly and saying, we're your real family. They never loved you. We love you. They loved you like the way people love slippers, like an old used pair of slippers. But they love their boys because that's their blood. And we're your blood, and that's how we love you. So you're staying with us now.
他们一直找借口。嗯，你需要等等。我们还有其他地方要去。我记得在某个时候，我的亲生父亲非常和善地把我拉到一边说，我们才是你真正的家人。他们从不爱你。我们爱你。他们爱你就像人们爱拖鞋一样，像一双破旧的拖鞋。但他们爱他们的儿子，因为那是他们的血脉。我们才是你的血脉，这就是我们爱你的方式。所以你现在留在这里。
They don't let her leave, and she's really confused. Of course my US parents love me. They must love me. But then if they loved me, why aren't they coming to get me?
他们不让她离开，她非常困惑。当然，我在美国的父母爱我。他们一定爱我。但如果他们爱我，为什么不来接我呢？
Unbeknownst to her, her US parents are trying to find out where she is. But no one will tell them. To make matters worse, her US parents are not legally Shamyla's parents. The adoption was never formal. She was just handed over. So they have no legal claim to their daughter. And there's nothing Shamyla could do. She was 12.
她不知道的是，她在美国的父母一直在试图寻找她的下落。但没人告诉他们。更糟糕的是，她的美国父母在法律上不是沙米拉的父母。领养从未正式化。她只是被交给了他们。所以他们对女儿没有法律主张权。而沙米拉什么也做不了。她才12岁。
Even if I fantasized about running away to another city and seeing other relatives, I was like, how will I do it? What will I do? Where will I get the money? How will I get on a train? How will I get on a plane? What will I do?
即使我幻想过逃到另一个城市去找其他亲戚，我也会想，我该怎么做？我会做什么？我从哪弄钱？我怎么上火车？我怎么上飞机？我该怎么办？
You were trapped.
你被困住了。
I was trapped, yeah.
我被困住了，是的。
She says her birth parents told her when she was growing up, whenever they saw her, it was upsetting to them. They thought, she's too Americanized. They were incredibly traditional, even for Pakistan, which is already very patriarchal. Women are expected to be subordinate. And if their purity is questioned, like if they're even seen speaking to a man in a public place, their family's reputation could be ruined. And the whole family could be ostracized from the community for it.
她说她的亲生父母告诉她，当她长大后，每次看到她，他们都很心烦。他们认为，她太美国化了。即使对巴基斯坦来说，他们也极其传统，那里的男权思想已经很重了。女性被期望处于从属地位。如果她们的贞洁受到质疑，比如如果她们在公共场合被看见与男人说话，家族的声誉可能会被毁掉。整个家庭都可能因此被社区排斥。
This is especially the case in Peshawar, where her birth parents lived. And Shamyla, a suburban Maryland tween, didn't understand that this was the world she lived in now. She says everything about the way she acted was wrong in their eyes. They didn't approve of the music she listened to or the books she read. They thought they were teaching her to be far too independent for a girl. At this rate, she'd become promiscuous any day now.
在白沙瓦更是如此，那是她亲生父母居住的地方。而沙米拉，一个马里兰州郊区的青少年，并不明白她现在生活在这样一个世界里。她说，在她眼中，她所做的一切都是错的。他们不赞成她听的音乐或读的书。他们认为他们在教她变得太独立了，这不适合一个女孩。照这样下去，她随时都会变得生活不检点。
And since they didn't trust her not to be, they kept her under house arrest, confining her to a corner of the house that consisted of a bedroom and a bathroom. And they confiscated her cassettes and her books. Her birth father would lecture to her for hours.
由于他们不相信她，他们将她软禁起来，把她限制在房子里一间包括卧室和浴室的角落里。他们没收了她的磁带和书。她的亲生父亲会连续几个小时给她训话。
His favorite three topics were America is a bad place, especially for girls. American women are loose character and horrible. The second topic was your adopted family never really loved you. Never. And the third topic was so here's what you're going to do when you get married. These are your wifely duties, including your sexual obligations to your husband.
他最喜欢的三个话题是：美国是一个糟糕的地方，尤其是对女孩来说。美国女性性格放荡，非常糟糕。第二个话题是：你的养父母从不真正爱你。从来没有。第三个话题是：这就是你结婚后要做的。这是你的妻子职责，包括你对丈夫的性义务。
He'd also lecture her about the rules she needed to follow. Some were the normal rules of an observant Muslim home. She couldn't go out without being covered, make eye contact, wear her hair down. Others were cultural. She couldn't hug people, wear glasses when guests came over, speak English or Urdu, which would be seen as a sign of modernity. Only Pashto, the language of the region, was allowed.
他还会给她训话，谈论她需要遵守的规矩。有些是虔诚的穆斯林家庭的正常规矩。她出门必须遮住身体，不能与人有眼神接触，头发不能散开。其他则是文化上的。她不能拥抱人，有客人在时不能戴眼镜，不能说英语或乌尔都语，因为这会被视为现代化的标志。只允许使用该地区的语言——普什图语。
She couldn't serve herself food before her brothers. She was barely allowed to eat. They thought she needed to be thin to get married, so they locked the fridge. She says if she messed up, she was beaten with a kitchen squeegee, which cut her face open, or a walking stick. That was the worst one, she says.
她不能在哥哥们之前给自己盛饭。她几乎不被允许吃饭。他们认为她需要瘦一点才能结婚，所以他们锁上了冰箱。她说，如果她做错了什么，她就会被厨房的刮水板抽打，脸被割开了，或者被手杖抽打。那是她说的最糟糕的一次。
The second worst one was with a golf club. And the third worst one was with cleats near my eye.
第二糟糕的是用高尔夫球杆，第三糟糕的是在眼睛附近用带钉球鞋抽打。
They took cleats and hit you with them.
他们拿钉鞋打你？
No, I think I got kicked.
不，我想我是被踢的。
She asked me not to reach out to her birth parents to confirm these details because she was worried for her safety. And I didn't. The members of her family here in the States confirmed that this is what her birth parents are like. And her mother and therapist corroborated that her story of being abused has always remained consistent.
她要求我不要联系她的亲生父母以核实这些细节，因为她担心自己的安全。我没有这么做。她在美国的家人证实了她亲生父母确实是这样的人。她的母亲和治疗师也证实了她遭受虐待的说法一直保持一致。
I remember after every time they would beat me, I put an X on whatever calendar I had and be like, this will never happen again. I will be so good now that this will never happen again.
我记得每次他们打完我之后，我都会在日历上打个叉，心想，这种事永远不会再发生了。我现在会表现得非常好，这样这种事就永远不会再发生了。
Like from this day forward, I'll finally be a good girl.
就像从今天开始，我会成为一个乖女孩。
Yep.
是的。
Did you feel like you'd never be the girl they wanted you to be?
你觉得你永远无法成为他们想要的那个女孩吗？
No, I thought eventually, I'm going to get there. I just have to keep trying.
不，我以为我最终会做到的。我只是必须不断尝试。
Mhm.
嗯。
I really thought that eventually, I'm going to become that person.
我真的以为我最终会成为那个人。
And you wanted to be that person?
你想成为那个人吗？
I think that I thought I had no choice.
我想是因为我觉得我别无选择。
She wasn't just physically abused. As she got older, she says she was also sexually abused by her brother. And finally, into this bleakness comes a book, the book, Little Women.
她不仅遭受身体虐待。随着年龄增长，她说她还受到哥哥的性虐待。最后，在这片阴暗中，出现了一本书，《小妇人》。
So one of my friends noticed the book at a book fair at our school. All these books had come from Singapore, and there was Little Women. I was like, I know this book, and I want it. And I remember thinking, oh my god, I read that book when I was little. I had a huge, beautiful illustrated copy growing up. And I said to my friend Mirjana, I was like, Mirjana, can you please buy it? It's 10 rupees, and I'll pay you back.
我的一位朋友在学校的书展上注意到了这本书。所有的书都来自新加坡，其中就有《小妇人》。我说，我知道这本书，我想要它。我记得我当时想，噢天哪，我小时候读过这本书。我成长过程中有一本巨大的、精美的插图版。我对我的朋友米尔贾纳说，我说，米尔贾纳，你能帮我买下它吗？只要10卢比，我会还给你的。
She'd tried smuggling books home before, but she'd always been caught. She hid the book inside her mattress pad underneath the bed, and she broke it into sections, roughly eight piles, so that it didn't make the mattress stick up in any way. When she heard her family go out, she'd wait and then carefully unzip the mattress pad and take a section of the book out at a time. Whichever one she pulled out first, she read.
她以前试过把书偷偷带回家，但总是被发现。她把书藏在床垫下的垫子里，把它拆成了几部分，大约八叠，这样就不会让床垫凸起。当她听到家人出去时，她会等待，然后小心地拉开床垫垫子的拉链，一次取出一部分阅读。无论她先抽出哪一部分，她就读哪一部分。
It was the book of my life. It was the only book I had to escape. It was the only book that I had to actually read over and over again. And I kind of memorized it.
这是我生命中的书。它是唯一让我可以逃避的书。它是唯一让我可以反复阅读的书。我几乎把它背下来了。
I'm going to read you some quotes from the book.
我要读给你听书里的一些话。
OK.
好的。
And just interrupt if you know where it is or what this is about. And then I'm going to just randomly open the book.
如果你知道这是哪里的内容或者这是关于什么的，就打断我。然后我会随机翻开这本书。
[LAUGHS] This feels like a pop quiz.
（笑）这感觉像是一场突击测试。
Yeah. Ooh. "'Mercy on me. Beth loves Laurie,' she said, sitting down on--"
是的。噢。“‘天哪。贝丝爱劳里，’她说，坐在……”
Oh, this is when Beth is ill, and Beth is changing. And she thinks the secret is that Beth is in love with Laurie.
噢，这是贝丝生病时，贝丝正在发生变化。她认为秘密是贝丝爱上了劳里。
"Mrs. March and Jo were deep in their own affairs when a sound from Meg made them look up to see her staring at her note."
“马奇太太和乔正沉浸在自己的事务中，这时梅格发出的一声响动使她们抬头看到她正盯着她的便条。”
Oh, that's when Meg has written to Mr. Brooke, and he actually writes back. But it was Laurie pretending to be Mr. Brooke.
噢，那是梅格写信给布鲁克先生，他真的回信了。但那是劳里假装是布鲁克先生写的。
We did this eight times, and she's able to get everything I read within seconds.
我们这样做了八次，我读的每一段她都能在几秒钟内答出来。
You're good at this.
你很擅长这个。
[LAUGHS] I told you I read this book over, and over, and over.
（笑）我告诉过你，我把这本书读了一遍、又一遍、又一遍。
How many times?
读了多少遍？
Oh, hundreds. By now, it's probably thousands.
噢，几百遍。到现在，可能已经几千遍了。
If you haven't read Little Women, it's basically about four sisters, the March sisters. Meg, the oldest, is the responsible one. Jo is the rebel and the writer. Beth is sick. And Amy, the youngest, is a spoiled brat. Their father's serving in the Civil War, and their mother is raising them alone. The book follows these girls from childhood into adulthood.
如果你还没读过《小妇人》，它主要是关于四个姐妹，马奇姐妹的故事。梅格是长女，负责任；乔是叛逆者和作家；贝丝生病了；艾米是最小的，被宠坏了。她们的父亲在南北战争中服役，母亲独自抚养她们。书记录了这些女孩从童年到成年的过程。
Were there parts of the book that you would just read over and over? Like, your favorite parts.
书里有没有你反复阅读的部分？比如你最喜欢的部分。
I loved reading the parts in the beginning when the two sisters would talk to each other, Meg and Jo, and their bond. Because I didn't have a sister, and I had no one to talk to. And I really loved the scenes about parties and stuff.
我喜欢读开头的部分，姐妹俩——梅格和乔互相交谈以及她们的羁绊。因为我没有姐妹，我没有人可以交谈。而且我真的很喜欢关于派对之类的场景。
She loved these scenes because they mirrored her life in a really specific way. Her birth parents were upper middle class, and they wanted to use Shamyla to marry into a higher class. So they dressed her up and took her to social events to show her off. In the book, there are events like this that the March sisters go to.
她喜欢这些场景是因为它们以一种非常具体的方式映射了她的生活。她的亲生父母是中产阶级上层，他们想利用沙米拉嫁入更高的阶层。所以他们给她打扮，带她去参加社交活动来展示她。在书中，马奇姐妹也会参加这样的活动。
There's a chapter about Meg and Jo going to a party in the very beginning. And they're not out yet in society. And I was like, oh my god. This 1860-something book is what's happening in Peshawar in 1990. Oh my god. It's the same thing. I'm not out yet in society, and I have to be very careful how I present myself.
开头有一章关于梅格和乔去参加派对。她们还没有在社交界亮相。我当时就想，噢天哪。这本书写于1860年代，而这正是1990年白沙瓦正在发生的事情。噢天哪。是一模一样的事。我还没有在社交界亮相，我必须非常小心我展示自己的方式。
In a way, Little Women was the perfect book for Shamyla's situation because it's like a how-to for girls, a survival guide. Like most women who read the book, the sister Shamyla relates to the most is Jo. She was my favorite, too.
在某种程度上，《小妇人》是沙米拉情况的完美书籍，因为它就像一本女孩的使用手册，一本生存指南。像大多数读这本书的女性一样，沙米拉认同度最高的姐妹是乔。她也是我最喜欢的。
I was raised in a strict religion, and my life was supposed to be about marriage and motherhood. And then Jo came into my orbit and showed me I could have ambition, and be improper, and break the rules. And I loved her for it. And that's how Shamyla felt. Jo helped Shamyla hold onto the identity her family was trying so hard to squash.
我在一个严格的宗教环境中长大，我的生活应该是关于婚姻和母性的。然后乔进入了我的轨道，向我展示我可以有野心，可以不循规蹈矩，可以打破规矩。我因此而爱她。这就是沙米拉的感觉。乔帮助沙米拉保持了她家庭拼命想要抹掉的身份。
There is a part where Jo and Laurie go running, and Meg scolds her and says, when will you learn to be ladylike? And she says, I hope never. I always want to run, and I always want to romp.
有一部分是乔和劳里去跑步，梅格责备她说，你什么时候才能学会像个淑女？她说，我希望永远不会。我一直想奔跑，一直想玩耍。
And I thought, me, too. I never want to have to stop being spirited and independent. And I remember Jo had a temper in the book, and I thought, I have a temper, too. And she's working really hard to curb it. I was like, I am, too.
我想，我也是。我永远不想被迫停止做一个有活力和独立的人。我记得乔在书中有脾气，我想，我也有脾气。她一直在努力克制它。我想，我也是。
I didn't have any of the freedom Jo had. But in my heart, I was just as feisty and independent. So I think it's very funny when nowadays, my friends are like, well, you were so meek. And I was like, I was never meek. That's just a facade. [LAUGHS] I'm Jo. I get her.
我没有乔那样的自由。但在心里，我同样热情而独立。所以我觉得很有趣，现在我的朋友们说，好吧，你太温顺了。我就说，我从来都不温顺。那只是一个伪装。（笑）我是乔。我懂她。
But in a way, what's so interesting is it's so literally like, your way of being Jo was reading about Jo. That's where you actually got to be Jo.
但从某种角度看，最有趣的是，你做乔的方式就是阅读关于乔的内容。那就是你真正能够成为乔的地方。
Yeah. I couldn't really do anything else.
是的。我真的做不了别的。
In the book, Jo writes stories. Shamyla loved to write, too. But she says the second year she was there, her birth father declared girls aren't supposed to write, and took a notebook filled with her stories and burned it in the backyard, and made her watch. In the book, Jo writes her stories alone in the attic. This gave Shamyla the idea to sneak into her bathroom with a fountain pen and paper and write.
书中，乔写故事。沙米拉也喜欢写作。但她说她在那里生活的第二年，她的亲生父亲宣称女孩不应该写字，拿走了一个写满她故事的笔记本，并在后院烧掉了它，还强迫她观看。书中，乔独自在阁楼里写故事。这给了沙米拉灵感，让她偷偷溜进浴室，用钢笔和纸写字。
And then I would wash all the ink off the paper, crumple up the wet paper, and throw it out the hole in the window mesh.
然后我会把纸上所有的墨水洗掉，把湿纸揉成一团，从窗户网的洞里扔出去。
Wait, you would write the stories, and then erase everything you'd written.
等等，你会写故事，然后擦掉你写的一切。
So there was a hose that attached from the tub to the sink. And so I would take that hose and wash all the ink off.
所以有一个从浴缸连接到水槽的软管。我就会拿着那个软管把所有的墨水洗掉。
Down the drain of the--
顺着那个……的下水道
There was a floor drain, and I would make sure that the floor drain was not blue with the blue ink and that there was no sign of ink that had fallen off the papers.
有一个地漏，我会确保地漏没有被蓝墨水染蓝，确保没有从纸上滴落的墨水痕迹。
Shamyla knew how her family would react if they caught her writing, or if they found her copy of Little Women and read any of it. Like, there's a boy in the book. His name is Laurie. He and Jo have an innocent flirtation. But Shamyla says if her birth parents read that part, they'd think--
沙米拉知道如果家人发现她在写作，或者发现她那本《小妇人》并读到其中的内容，他们会怎么反应。比如，书里有个男孩。他叫劳里。他和乔有天真的调情。但沙米拉说，如果她的亲生父母读到那部分，他们会想——
You don't go over to an adolescent boy's house ever. There's no innocence in this. In real life, Jo and Laurie would be doing very bad things. This is not right.
你永远不该去一个青春期男孩的家。这其中没有天真。在现实生活中，乔和劳里会做非常坏的事。这不正确。
They're saying in real life, Jo and Laurie would be getting it on?
他们是说在现实生活中，乔和劳里会发生关系？
Basically.
基本上是这样。
I mean, that would have been a better book, right?
我的意思是，那本来会是一本更好的书，对吧？
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
I loved that. Oh my gosh. That was, like, my fanfiction. I would write that.
我爱死那个了。噢我的天。那就是我的同人小说。我会写那个的。
That's so funny.
那太有趣了。
After a year, Shamyla's American mother was allowed to visit her. Shamyla told her what was happening. Her American mother cried and begged for her extended family to intervene and send Shamyla back to the States, but it was useless. Shamyla felt abandoned and hopeless. So she gave in. Did her best to make herself into the obedient Pashtan girl they wanted her to be.
一年后，沙米拉的美国母亲被允许探望她。沙米拉告诉了她正在发生的事情。她的美国母亲哭了，恳求她大家族干预并将沙米拉送回美国，但这毫无用处。沙米拉感到被遗弃和绝望。所以她屈服了。尽她所能把自己变成他们想要的顺从的普什图女孩。
There's a scene in the book, one I hated because it was so sad, that Shamyla read over and over again.
书里有一个场景，一个我讨厌的场景，因为太悲伤了，沙米拉反复阅读。
I reread Beth's dying a lot because there was this sense of helplessness. And I really understood that in a way that a lot of people don't. Because I knew when something's inevitable, and it's going to happen, they keep saying the tide's going out in the book.
我反复读贝丝临死那一段，因为有一种无助感。我以一种很多人无法理解的方式真正理解了那种感觉。因为我知道当某事是必然的，当它注定发生时，书里一直说潮水退去了。
And I was like, yeah, when the tide goes out, you just have to go with it. You can't fight it. I understood that on a level I couldn't even explain. I just knew what that meant.
我想，是的，当潮水退去时，你只能随波逐流。你无法抗争。我以一种我甚至无法解释的程度理解了这一点。我只是知道那意味着什么。
It sounds like their world feels so real to you.
听起来他们的世界对你来说感觉非常真实。
I know, it really does. I felt like I lived with them sometimes.
我知道，真的如此。我觉得有时我就和他们住在一起。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Like, I felt like I was watching them. Like, I was, like, the servant or something, watching. I felt like I lived in the attic, and I could go downstairs and see them. They couldn't see me, but I could see them.
就像，我感觉我在看着他们。就像，我是一个仆人还是什么的，在观察。我感觉我住在阁楼里，我可以下楼去看他们。他们看不见我，但我看得见他们。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
And I would join the world. Like, I would join in.
我会加入那个世界。就像，我会参与进去。
Her real world, of course, was much darker. By the time she got to 17 or 18, she concluded that there's really only one way out to escape her family and maybe even have a happy life.
她的真实世界当然要黑暗得多。当她长到17或18岁时，她得出结论，逃离家庭甚至可能过上幸福生活的唯一出路就是结婚。
I was like, OK, so the way out is marriage. So I have to play this game to get married. And I started to actually kind of be like, OK, so in Little Women, you know how Meg goes to society dances and wears her glove and skirts, putting her hair up? I was like, I can do this. I can do this to get the best possible way out. I was really thinking about how to create my life with someone else and what that would look like. And so I had stopped so much caring about going home or going back.
我想，好吧，所以出路是婚姻。所以我必须玩这场游戏来结婚。我开始真的有点想，好吧，在《小妇人》里，你知道梅格是如何去参加社交舞会，戴上手套和裙子，把头发盘起来的？我想，我可以做到。我可以这样做来获得最好的出路。我真的在考虑如何与另一个人创造我的生活，那会是什么样子。所以我也就不那么在乎回家或回去了。
And marriage is actually what the second part of Little Women is about. The second half of the book is very different from the first. It covers domestic duties and how the girls let go of their wild ways to become good wives. Shamyla, not a big fan of part two.
而婚姻实际上是《小妇人》第二部分的内容。书的后半部分和前半部分非常不同。它涵盖了家务职责以及女孩们如何放下狂野的本性成为好妻子。沙米拉不是第二部分的忠实粉丝。
The second book, I remember thinking, I don't like this part. I like going back to their childhood and reading that part again and again and again.
第二本书，我记得我当时想，我不喜欢这一部分。我喜欢回到她们的童年，反复阅读那部分。
Oh, the second part is the worst.
噢，第二部分是最糟糕的。
I know. It's so, so, so sad.
我知道。它真的、真的、真的太悲伤了。
I think I'd really forgotten the message of the second half of the book. And it it's just kind of infuriating when you realize how, in some ways, it feels almost like a propaganda for becoming the way you're supposed to be.
我想我真的忘记了书后半部分传达的信息。当你意识到在某些方面，它感觉几乎像是让你成为你应该成为的人的宣传工具时，这真的很让人愤怒。
Yeah, I remember thinking when Meg gets married, they have a whole chapter about how she loses her freedom. And I was like, oh god, I don't want that to be my story when I get married. I understood a lot of that because that was what was being asked of me at that time, to give up, give up, give up in order to be a woman to live in this society and be married and have a family.
是的，我记得当梅格结婚时，他们有一整章关于她如何失去自由的内容，我想，噢天哪，我不想在我结婚时成为我的故事。我理解其中的大部分，因为那是我当时被要求做的，为了成为一个能在这个社会生存、结婚并拥有家庭的女人而不断放弃、放弃、再放弃。
A friend at Shamyla's school told her she had a brother that Shamyla could marry who would treat her well. So she began corresponding with him via her friend. But her family found out, and they were terrified that their reputation was going to be destroyed by it. Girls do not communicate directly with boys, and they did what lots of families might do. They pulled her out of school and quickly started arranging her marriage to a 30-year-old man.
沙米拉学校里的一位朋友告诉她，她有一个哥哥可以让沙米拉嫁给他，他会善待她。于是她开始通过这位朋友与他通信。但她的家人发现了，他们非常害怕声誉会因此被毁。女孩不得与男孩直接交流，于是他们做了许多家庭可能会做的事。他们让她退学，并很快开始安排她嫁给一个30岁的男人。
As part of their damage control, they decided to send Shamyla away for a few weeks. But their only relatives who weren't in Peshawar were in America. So they made arrangements to send her back. And while she was there, her birth father and mother wanted her to learn new skills that would add to her bride price, the money the groom's family would be expected to pay them.
作为损害控制的一部分，他们决定把沙米拉送走几周。但他们唯一不在白沙瓦的亲戚在美国。所以他们做了安排把她送回去。当她在那儿时，她的亲生父母希望她学习新的技能，以增加她的“聘礼”，即新郎家庭预期支付给他们的钱。
He sent me with a whole list. He was like, you have to learn driving, shorthand, swimming.
他给了我一整张清单。他说，你必须学会开车、速记、游泳。
It just seems like after all the work they did to get you to stay and also their plans to marry you off, it just seems crazy that they would let you go back.
在他们做了这么多工作让你留下来以及安排你嫁出去之后，他们竟然让你回去，这看起来太疯狂了。
Well, it's funny because she even said something crazy. She's like, if they're going to do anything to fix your face-- because remember, they cut my face open-- she's like, ask them if they can put a mole down there, like Cindy Crawford. And so I was like, OK, let's add mole to the list of things that will happen.
嗯，这很有趣，因为她甚至说了些疯狂的话。她说，如果他们要修复你的脸——因为记住，他们割开了我的脸——她说，问问他们能不能在那儿点个痣，像辛迪·克劳馥那样。所以我说，好的，把点痣加到要做的事情清单上。
They send her to stay with her US parents. Her birth father is so confident that Shamyla is one of them now, that she'll obediently return to Pakistan, he doesn't question letting her go. A female chaperone traveled with her.
他们送她去和她的美国父母住在一起。她的亲生父亲如此自信，认为沙米拉现在是他们的一员了，她会顺从地回到巴基斯坦，以至于他并没有质疑让她回去。一位女性监护人陪同她一起旅行。
So we walked onto the tarmac. I climbed up in the plane. And as the plane took off, I just started crying nonstop because I knew I wasn't coming back. I just knew. I didn't know how I knew it. I don't why I knew it. And then watching Pakistan slip away, and I'm like, I'm not going back here. It's never happening.
我们走上停机坪。我爬上飞机。当飞机起飞时，我开始不停地哭，因为我知道我不会再回来了。我就是知道。我不知道我怎么知道的。我不知道为什么我知道。看着巴基斯坦逐渐远去，我想，我不会再回这里了。永远不会了。
And was it relief?
那是种解脱吗？
No, I was sad. I was really, really sad. I was like, goodbye, life that I knew.
不，我很伤心。我真的很、真的很伤心。我想，再见了，我所熟悉的生活。
At first, she had a hard time coming back to America. She was in total culture shock. She could hardly speak English. She didn't recognize her little brothers. The internet existed now. It was like she'd woken up from a coma.
起初，她很难回到美国。她陷入了完全的文化冲击。她几乎不会说英语。她认不出她的小弟弟们了。互联网现在存在了。就像她从昏迷中醒来一样。
I remember thinking, like, I still like big hair. And everyone's like, that ended in 1989. No one does that anymore. And I was like, but I like that. They're like, no, now we straighten our hair. And I was like, I don't like that. Well, you have to.
我记得我想，我还是喜欢高耸的发型。每个人都说，那在1989年就结束了。没人再那样做了。我说，但我喜欢那样。他们说，不，现在我们把头发拉直了。我说，我不喜欢那样。嗯，你必须喜欢。
She enrolled in community college, but she'd been so indoctrinated, it was hard for her to just switch it off. She'd see women in skirts and catch herself judging them. For the first few years, she was a mess. Trying to switch off the ideology was nearly impossible. She started to see a therapist who helped her process the extent of what happened to her.
她进入社区大学，但她被灌输得太深了，很难一下子摆脱。她看到穿着裙子的女性，会发现自己在那儿评判她们。最初几年，她过得很糟。试图摆脱这种意识形态几乎是不可能的。她开始看治疗师，帮助她处理发生在她身上的一切。
There's something her mother said to me on the phone I can't stop thinking about. It's something she told her little sister once. "Between you and me, we've ruined Shamyla's life."
她母亲在电话里对我说了一句话，我一直无法忘怀。那是她曾经告诉她小妹妹的话。“你我之间，我们毁了沙米拉的一生。”
It's been 23 years since she returned. Her life actually diverged from the second half of Little Women, the part she didn't like. She didn't get married, and she's independent. She runs her own practice as a therapist and social worker. She specifically works with people who suffer from trauma because she understands it so well herself. But sometimes she still returns to Little Women.
她回来已经23年了。她的生活实际上偏离了《小妇人》的后半部分，也就是她不喜欢的那部分。她没有结婚，她很独立。她经营着自己的心理咨询和社工诊所。她专门与遭受创伤的人合作，因为她自己非常了解那种感觉。但有时她还是会回到《小妇人》。
Well, it comes up in different situations. I'll be like, OK, so-- the other day, I actually-- this is funny. My friend has twins, and she was telling me, like, god, I'm so tired. And they don't listen, and my husband is so busy. And I referred her to the chapter of Meg trying to discipline her twins. And I was like, read this. This will help you.
嗯，它在不同情况下会出现。我会想，好吧，所以——有一天，实际上——这很有趣。我的朋友有双胞胎，她告诉我说，天哪，我太累了。他们不听话，我丈夫又那么忙。我向她推荐了梅格努力管教双胞胎的那一章。我说，读这个。这会对你有帮助。
Wait. Are you constantly like-- do your friends have a joke, where, like, oh, not another Little Women reference?
等等。你是那种……你的朋友是不是有个笑话，比如，噢，别再来一个《小妇人》的引用了？
No, I think that they think it's funny that I like the book so much, but I don't think anyone really understands why.
不，我认为她们觉得我这么喜欢这本书很有趣，但我不认为有人真正理解为什么。
Wait. So it's, like, your only frame of reference.
等等。所以这是你唯一的参考框架。
Yeah.
是的。
When she's having a hard time or making a decision, she asks the question, opens the book, and whatever passage she reads, it's her answer from the March sisters. And she also has this ritual.
当她遇到困难或做决定时，她会提出问题，翻开书，无论读到哪一段，那就是来自马奇姐妹的答案。她还有一个仪式。
So every year on my birthday, I find the corresponding age that I am for the chapter I am, and I read that.
所以每年在我生日那天，我都会找到与我年龄相对应的章节，并读那一章。
In other words, chapter 30 when she turned 30, chapter 31 when she turned 31.
换句话说，30岁时读第30章，31岁时读第31章。
To be like, so what is this year going to be about in my life? What's it telling me?
心想，这一年我的生活会是关于什么的？它在告诉我什么？
So it's almost like your magic eight ball.
所以这几乎就像你的魔力8号球。
Yeah, kind of. It's like my Bible.
是的，某种程度上。它就像我的《圣经》。
What did you turn this year?
你今年多大？
I'm 41.
我41岁。
And what chapter?
哪一章？
Oh, it's called "Learning to Forget." It's when Laurie's trying to forget Jo, and he starts falling in love with Amy.
噢，那一章叫“学会忘记”。那是劳里试图忘记乔，并开始爱上艾米的时候。
And how do you think that's going to relate to this year?
你认为那与今年有什么关系？
Maybe this year, finally, someone's going to fall in love with me. [LAUGHS] The right one, not all the wrong ones.
也许今年，终于，有人会爱上我。（笑）对的那一个，而不是所有错的那几个。
There are 47 chapters in Little Women. In six years, she'll turn 48, and she doesn't know what she'll do. She says maybe she'll start from the beginning again. And whereas the book used to be a way of escaping her room in Pakistan, now it's a way of returning to that world she built alone in her room. It's as if the March sisters are all still living there, and she's the one who left them behind.
《小妇人》有47章。六年内，她将满48岁，她不知道自己会做什么。她说也许她会从头再来。曾经这本书是逃离巴基斯坦房间的一种方式，现在它是回到她在房间里独自建造的那个世界的一种方式。就像马奇姐妹都还住在那里，而她是那个把她们留在身后的人。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show. Shamyla told a version of this story herself on the storytelling podcast Risk, which tapes for a live audience. You can hear that version and all those stories at risk-show.com.
埃尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一。沙米拉在播客Risk里亲自讲述了这个故事的某个版本，该节目为现场观众录制。你可以在risk-show.com收听那个版本和所有那些故事。
Coming up, Wu Tang is for the children, children of the future. So is Wu Tang the future? That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，武当是属于孩子的，属于未来的孩子。那么武当是未来吗？稍后在芝加哥公共广播的节目中继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on the show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, The Weight of Words, stories about the words that people turn to for comfort or strength. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Daddy Lessons.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“文字的重量”，关于人们向其寻求慰藉或力量的文字的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“爸爸的教训”。
So the most recent bit of serious parenting that my dad did with me-- and I say this realizing that this might be the very last life lesson he might give me, we are both getting up there in years-- was a protracted month-long campaign to switch from Excel to Quicken to keep track of my personal finances. He felt very strongly about this. And I just want to say yes, the numbers add up the same, no matter what software you use.
所以，我父亲最近对我进行的认真的教养工作——我意识到这可能是他给我的最后一个人生教训，我们俩的年纪都大了——是一场持续一个月的运动，要求我从Excel切换到Quicken来记录我的个人财务。他对此非常坚持。我只想说，是的，无论你使用什么软件，数字相加的结果都是一样的。
But Quicken-- I mean, don't get my dad started. He's a retired CPA. He had already trained me to save all my receipts. Please, that's basic.
但Quicken——我的意思是，别让我父亲开始说了。他是一位退休的注册会计师。他早就训练我保存所有的收据。拜托，那是基础。
And he went on with this at such length that at some point, I realized, oh, switching software was not a piece of friendly financial advice. This was actual parenting happening. Not switching to Quicken meant an actual repudiation of him as a father. It would actually be a failure of parenthood.
他对此滔滔不绝，以至于在某个时刻，我意识到，噢，切换软件并不是友好的财务建议。这实际上是真正的教养。不切换到Quicken意味着对我父亲的一种否定。那实际上会是养育子女的失败。
Parents try to shape who we are in their own image so often. They make sure their kids are exposed to whatever-- modern art, sports, nature, science, theater, whatever they love. They train them to be the world's greatest tennis player or golfer, that kind of thing.
父母总是试图以自己的形象塑造我们。他们确保孩子接触到任何东西——现代艺术、体育、自然、科学、戏剧，任何他们热爱的事物。他们训练他们成为世界上最伟大的网球运动员或高尔夫球手，诸如此类。
My friend, Adam, came up with a scheme like that.
我的朋友亚当也想出了这样一个方案。
Neil Drumming is one of our producers here. His friend Adam is Adam Mansbach, a writer.
尼尔·德鲁明是我们这里的制作人之一。他的朋友亚当是亚当·曼斯巴赫，一位作家。
Adam is a DJ, a record collector. And he wanted his daughter, Vivian, to love music the way he loved music, exactly the way he loved music.
亚当是一位DJ，一位唱片收藏家。他希望他的女儿维维安像他热爱音乐那样热爱音乐，完全按照他热爱音乐的方式。
One of the things I feel like I got right about parenting is that I never played Viv any kids' music because I understood that any song that you played a two-year-old, a three-year-old, might become their favorite song, and then you would have to listen to it 20 times a day. So I never played her anything I wasn't willing to listen to 20 times a day. So she from a very young age was listening to a lot of music I liked.
关于养育子女，我觉得我做对的一件事是，我从来没有给维芙放过任何儿童音乐，因为我明白，你给两三岁孩子放的任何歌曲，都可能成为他们最喜欢的歌，然后你就得每天听20遍。所以我从不给她放任何我不想每天听20遍的东西。所以她很小的时候就听了很多我喜欢的音乐。
Is that a thing that you got right about parenting, or is that a thing that you just did for yourself?
那是你在育儿方面做对的一件事，还是你只是为你自己做的一件事？
I mean, [LAUGHS] aren't the two synonymous really, Neil? I'm not sure what the difference is.
我的意思是，（笑）这两者不是同义词吗，尼尔？我不确定区别在哪里。
Adam likes '80s and '90s hip hop perhaps more than me, which is saying a lot. Anyway, he fed Vivian a steady diet of classic material-- A Tribe Called Quest, Public Enemy, Run-DMC, Das EFX.
亚当喜欢80和90年代的嘻哈音乐，可能比我还喜欢，这已经很说明问题了。无论如何，他给维维安灌输了经典的素材——部落呼唤、人民公敌、Run-DMC、Das EFX。
There was probably a year, probably two years, where the Stetsasonic record In Full Gear got more play in our house than any other record. We may be the only household in North America that can say that, that in the year 2014, we listened to In Full Gear more than any other album.
可能有一年，或者两年，Stetsasonic的唱片《In Full Gear》在我们家播放的次数比任何其他唱片都多。我们可能是北美唯一能这么说的家庭，在2014年，我们听《In Full Gear》的次数超过了任何其他专辑。
What is that record, '88?
那是哪年的唱片，88年？
Yeah, it came out in '88.
是的，它在88年发行。
This exposure therapy approach to parenting has been known to fail. I grew up surrounded by beds that were always made. But if you walked into my apartment now, you'd see no evidence of that. In Adam's case, though, it worked. He noticed that by the time she was six years old, Vivian could rap along to any hip hop song he played her.
这种暴露疗法式的育儿方式众所周知会失败。我是在铺好的床上长大的。但如果你现在走进我的公寓，你看不到任何那样的痕迹。不过在亚当的案例中，它奏效了。他注意到，当维维安六岁时，她已经可以跟着他放的任何嘻哈歌曲说唱了。
She would memorize it, and she would be very much in the pocket and just not missing a beat. I remember one of the songs that we played a lot was "The Choice is Yours" remix by Black Sheep. I remember recording her just on my phone, doing the third verse of the song, the famous third verse of the song, "Engine, engine, number nine."
她会把它记下来，而且会非常合拍，完全不会错过节拍。我记得我们播放很多的一首歌是Black Sheep的《The Choice is Yours》混音版。我记得我录下了她在手机上说唱那首歌的第三段，那段著名的第三段，“引擎，引擎，九号”。
(RAPPING) If my train goes off the track, pick it up! Pick it up! Pick it up! Back on the scene, crispy and clean. You can try, but then why?
（说唱）如果我的火车偏离了轨道，捡起来！捡起来！捡起来！回到现场，清脆干净。你可以尝试，但为什么呢？
She had it, like, perfectly down, and it's not an easy verse to do. And I remember sending it to our friend, J. Period, who, in turn, sent it to Dres from Black Sheep. And he was like, yo, this is incredible. Tell her-- give her my props.
她掌握得非常完美，这不是一段容易的说唱。我记得我把它发给了我们的朋友J. Period，他转手又发给了Black Sheep的Dres。他说，哟，这太不可思议了。告诉她——替我向她致敬。
And I was like, yo, Viv. You're, like, six, so this means nothing to you, but Dres from Black Sheep said that you're dope. This is his song.
我说，哟，维芙。你才六岁，所以这对你来说没什么意义，但Black Sheep的Dres说你很酷。这是他的歌。
(RAPPING) Engine, engine, number nine on the New York transit line. If my train goes off the track, pick it up! Pick it up! Pick it up! Come on.
（说唱）引擎，引擎，九号，纽约交通线。如果我的火车偏离了轨道，捡起来！捡起来！捡起来！来吧。
Like a lot of guys our age, Adam tried his hand at being a rapper when he was younger. He joined a group. They made some songs that never quite went anywhere. He stayed in the hip hop world, though. He still has a lot of connections.
像我们这个年纪的很多家伙一样，亚当年轻时也尝试过成为一名说唱歌手。他加入了一个团体。他们做了一些从未真正出名的歌曲。不过他留在了嘻哈世界。他仍然有很多关系。
So he was thrilled to find out his daughter had some skills. And proud father that he is, he wanted more people to know. When another one of his entertainment industry buddies needed a theme song for a PBS kids show he was making called Bug Bites, Adam jumped at the chance to write Vivian some original material.
所以当发现女儿有一些天赋时，他非常激动。作为一位骄傲的父亲，他想让更多人知道。当他娱乐界的朋友需要为他制作的一档名为《Bug Bites》的PBS儿童节目创作主题曲时，亚当抓住了这个机会，为维维安写了一些原创素材。
(RAPPING) Six legs, eight legs, fly and crawl. Let's get it, world, come one, come all! Bugs can teach us so much more about the world. Let's go explore! Some of these facts are incredible knowledge, like bees keep flowers and vegetables growing.
（说唱）六条腿，八条腿，飞翔爬行。让我们一起吧，世界，来吧，都来吧！昆虫可以教会我们更多关于这个世界的知识。让我们去探索吧！其中一些事实是不可思议的知识，比如蜜蜂让花朵和蔬菜生长。
The show wound up not using the song, but Adam couldn't stop listening to it. He walked around playing it over and over in his headphones.
节目最终没有使用这首歌，但亚当听个不停。他走来走去，在耳机里反复播放它。
I mean, I knew she was skilled, but I sort of took it for granted. I was like, oh, that's just regular. Everybody can rhyme. Everybody I know can rhyme, you know? But I remember at that point being like, oh, you know what? This is really unique.
我的意思是，我知道她有天赋，但我有点把它当作理所当然。我想，噢，那很正常。每个人都会押韵。我认识的每个人都会押韵，你知道吗？但我记得在那时，我想，噢，你知道吗？这是非常独特的。
Did this change your expectations for what this could be?
这改变了你对这可能是什么的期望吗？
Yeah, I think it opened it up. It made me want to maybe want to do more and see where we could take this.
是的，我认为它打开了局面。它让我想要尝试做更多，看看我们能把这带到哪里。
And so they did.
于是他们就这样做了。
(RAPPING) Step into my office and have a seat.
（说唱）走进我的办公室，请坐。
He and Vivian would plan out songs during the winters in California and record with his music industry friends back east during the summers. Writing for Vivian, Adam would layer in little in-jokes they shared or references that he knew his daughter would appreciate. Like when she was into Percy Jackson, he'd weave in the Greek gods. When she was into Harry Potter, he worked that in.
他和维维安会在加州的冬天策划歌曲，并在夏天和他在东部的音乐界朋友一起录制。为维维安写作时，亚当会加入他们共享的小笑话或他知道女儿会欣赏的参考资料。就像她迷上《珀西·杰克逊》时，他会融入希腊神。当她迷上《哈利·波特》时，他也写了进去。
(RAPPING) Yeah. I'm nice with mine like Dumbledore, so what you want to rumble for?
（说唱）是的。我和邓布利多一样，我的东西很好，所以你想 rumble 什么？
Vivian recorded under the moniker the Jazz Wolf, a name that she came up with. Her first real taste of mainstream exposure came by way of a song that Adam, who's originally from Massachusetts, wrote for her to perform in a hometown Boston accent.
维维安以“爵士狼”的艺名录制，这是她自己想出的名字。她的第一次主流曝光是通过一首歌，亚当（原籍马萨诸塞州）为她写的，让她用家乡波士顿口音表演。
(RAPPING) My name's Clarissa, I'm wicked pissa. That girl Amber, I had to diss her. You opened up a powder keg, you freakin' chowder head. I'm a hot target, you're workin' star market.
（说唱）我叫克拉丽莎，我是个混蛋。那个叫安布尔的女孩，我得贬低她。你打开了火药桶，你这个疯子。我是个火热的目标，你在星巴克工作。
They made a video for the song, which made it onto the home page of the popular humor website, Funny or Die. But "Mush Lobsta" was more like a comedy bit than a banger. More DJ Jazzy Jeff and the Fresh Prince than it was Erik B. & Rakim. Adam didn't feel the song was representative of how he imagined Vivian as an artist.
他们为这首歌拍了视频，这视频登上了热门幽默网站“Funny or Die”的主页。但《Mush Lobsta》更像是一个喜剧片段，而不是一首热门歌曲。它更像DJ Jazzy Jeff and the Fresh Prince，而不是Erik B. & Rakim。亚当并不觉得这首歌代表了他想象中维维安作为艺术家的样子。
It was a funny song, but it was a funny song. It wasn't truly indicative of her skills as an MC because it was more focused on dropping Massachusetts-centric jokes.
这是一首有趣的歌，但仅仅是一首有趣的歌。它并不真正体现她作为MC的技能，因为它更多地专注于抛出马萨诸塞州中心的笑话。
(RAPPING) Eat a rind and drink a beer, and then I slap a critic. You're off the rez like Teddy was at Chappaquiddick.
（说唱）吃个皮喝杯啤酒，然后我给评论家一巴掌。你像泰迪在查帕奎迪克那样偏离了边界。
Adam had told me that his kid rapped early on, but I didn't understand how serious the two of them were about this until September of 2017 when I received an email from Adam with no subject heading. Attached to the email were two remarkably well produced songs, described in the body of the email simply as Jazz Wolf Heat Rocks. One of these so-called heat rocks featured Vivian, who I'd met once only briefly, but knew to be a small blonde white girl, rapping over a fluttery dancehall rhythm in full on Jamaican Patois.
亚当曾告诉我他的孩子很早就开始说唱，但我直到2017年9月收到亚当发来的一封没有主题的邮件，才明白他们俩对此有多认真。邮件附件是两首制作极其精良的歌曲，在邮件正文中简称为“爵士狼热曲”。这些所谓的热曲之一主角是维维安，我只见过她一次，而且很短暂，但我知道她是个金发碧眼的小女孩，她在充满舞厅节奏的背景下用牙买加克里奥尔语进行说唱。
[RAPPING IN JAMAICAN PATOIS]
（用牙买加克里奥尔语说唱）
Did listening to this reggae song, penned by a best-selling Jewish author for his nine-year-old and most likely recorded in or near his house on Martha's Vineyard, make me feel uncomfortable? Yeah, sure, a little. But I've been listening to hip hop a long time. And between all the sampling, and biting, and flipping styles, I've kind of made my peace with cultural appropriation. All I ask is that you give credit where credit is due and that you do your due diligence.
听这首由一位畅销犹太作家为他九岁的女儿创作、而且很可能是在玛莎葡萄园岛附近录制的雷鬼歌曲，让我感到不舒服吗？是的，当然，有一点。但我听嘻哈音乐很久了。在所有的采样、剽窃和转换风格之间，我已经与文化挪用达成了某种和解。我唯一的要求是你归功于该归功的人，并尽到你的尽职调查。
Neil, I should say that I had some misgivings about the song.
尼尔，我应该说我对这首歌有一些顾虑。
I was going to ask.
我正要问。
I definitely-- really, the first thing I did was send it to every Jamaican I knew and be like, yo, so what do you think about this?
我肯定——真的，我做的第一件事就是把它发给我认识的每一个牙买加人，心想，哟，所以你们觉得这个怎么样？
Anyway, the point is it wasn't just me and some Caribbean islanders who got this email. Adam was stepping up Vivian's game and had sent the Jazz Wolf de facto demo to just about every music industry contact he had. To a certain degree, it worked. Friends praised his daughter's music. Artists who Adam admired wanted to record with her. A big player in the music industry who'd had a hand in discovering Lauryn Hill suggested that they record more songs for a legitimate demo.
无论如何，重点是不仅是我和一些加勒比岛民收到了这封邮件。亚当一直在提高维维安的水准，并将“爵士狼”的事实上的演示小样发送给了他所有的音乐界联系人。在一定程度上，这奏效了。朋友们赞美他女儿的音乐。亚当钦佩的艺术家想要和她录音。一位曾经参与发掘劳琳·希尔的音乐界大人物建议他们录制更多歌曲作为一个合法的演示小样。
Bolstered by all this interest, Adam set out to write Vivian something really special. It was the kind of thing he'd have written for himself back in his rapping days-- multi-syllabic, rapid fire, a real showpiece designed to take the Jazz Wolf all the way to the next level. He was on a business trip when the ghost writer in him really took over.
在所有这些兴趣的推动下，亚当开始为维维安写一些真正特别的东西。那正是他在说唱日子里会为自己写的那种东西——多音节、快节奏，一个真正的展示品，旨在将“爵士狼”提升到新的水平。当他体内的代笔者真正接管时，他正在出差。
And I remember I had to go away for a week. I was in Chicago doing some stuff. And I was writing bars for her, and I was really trying to write the most complicated, difficult verses I could because I knew she could handle it. And I was like, this is going to be really fun. And I came back with the song, and we rehearsed it for a long time. We got a beat from Dug Infinite, an illustrious producer who worked with Common and all kinds of people.
我记得我不得不离开一周。我在芝加哥做一些事情。我正在为她写歌词，我真的在努力写出我能写出的最复杂、最困难的韵脚，因为我知道她能应付。我想，这会非常有趣。我带回了这首歌，我们练习了很长时间。我们从Dug Infinite那里得到了节奏，他是一位杰出的制作人，与Common和各种各样的人合作过。
And Viv had been practicing it for weeks. And we had plans to go to his house and record it. She was nine at the time. I remember because the chorus of the song played with the fact that she was nine. We flipped the chorus from 9 millimeter goes bang, and it was like, (RAPPING) wadadadang, wadadadang, 'ey, listen, 'cause I'm nine, and I kick enough slang.
维芙已经练习了几个星期。我们计划去他家录音。她当时九岁。我记得是因为这首歌的合唱部分玩了一个关于她九岁的事实。我们反转了9毫米手枪砰的一声的合唱，就像是，（说唱）wadadadang, wadadadang, 嘿，听着，因为我九岁，我说了很多俚语。
But despite all Adam's craft and preparation, there was an unforeseen but not unforeseeable issue with the talent.
但尽管亚当有所有的技艺和准备，这个人才出现了一个不可预见的但并非不可预见的问题。
She hadn't slept that night. We had a new baby. Vivian has two younger sisters, and the older of the two at that time was only a few months old and was up crying. And so Viv was, like, on no sleep.
她那天晚上没睡。我们有一个新婴儿。维维安有两个妹妹，其中较大的那个当时才几个月大，整夜啼哭。所以维芙是一夜没睡。
And I remember we got to the studio really early. And she was just exhausted and not really at her peak. And it was difficult for her to get it down. And we kind of called it-- we cut it short. I was like, you know what? Let's come back another day, Dug, because this isn't-- you know.
我记得我们很早就到了工作室。她精疲力竭，并不是处于最佳状态。她很难掌握它。我们有点放弃了——我们把它缩短了。我说，你知道吗？Dug，我们改天再来吧，因为这不……你知道。
I'm sorry. No, I'm sorry. I didn't mean to be like that.
对不起。不，对不起。我不是有意那样的。
Nah, are you kidding me? It's not your fault.
不，你在开玩笑吗？这不是你的错。
That's Vivian. She was in the studio with her dad during this interview. She's 11 now.
那是维维安。这次采访时她和爸爸在录音室里。她现在11岁。
Right? So I remember coming back from there, and Viv was tired. And in the car, she told me. She was like, Papa, I'm just not that into this right now. Something along those lines, like I'm not into you writing me these rap songs right now.
对吧？所以我记得从那里回来，维芙很累。在车里，她告诉了我。她说，爸爸，我现在对这个不太感兴趣。类似于那样的话，就像我不感兴趣你现在为我写这些说唱歌曲。
Vivian, do you remember this moment at all? This night?
维维安，你还记得这一刻吗？那天晚上？
I did. And I think that-- I think the reason I told him then was that-- this is going to sound really stupid. But I thought that because-- I think he would be less angry if he knew I was tired and didn't want to argue.
记得。我觉得……我觉得那时我告诉他的原因是——这听起来会很蠢。但我认为，因为……我觉得如果他知道我很累不想争吵，他会少生点气。
So you had already come to this decision.
所以你已经做出了这个决定。
Yeah. I mean, we hadn't talked about it, but I had already gone through it in my head what I was trying to say.
是的。我的意思是，我们没有谈论过，但我已经在脑子里经历过我试图说的话了。
OK, let's back up a bit. Vivian's dissatisfaction with how Adam was steering her rap career goes back long before this night-- back many car rides, in fact. She recalls trying to listen to new music while riding with her dad.
好的，让我们倒带一下。维维安对亚当如何引导她的人生说唱事业的不满远在那天晚上之前——事实上，远在许多次车程之前。她回忆起在和爸爸坐车时试图听新音乐。
Just flipping through radio stations in the car and him turning on a radio station, and I was like, oh, yeah, this one. He's like, oh, that's hot trash. We're not listening to that.
就在车里调换广播电台，他打开一个广播电台，我就说，噢，是的，这个。他却说，噢，那是垃圾。我们不听那个。
You see, Adam didn't realize this, but even while she'd been sharing his love of hip hop, Vivian had been developing her own taste. She'd started to enjoy more contemporary music, god forbid, even pop music-- Taylor Swift, and later Ke$ha, and Nicki Minaj, and Cardi B. But she'd been listening to music through Adam's ears long enough to understand and internalize just how much he wouldn't approve.
你看，亚当没有意识到这一点，但即使她一直在分享他对嘻哈音乐的热爱，维维安也一直在发展自己的品味。她开始享受更多当代音乐，天哪，甚至流行音乐——泰勒·斯威夫特，后来是Ke$ha、妮琪·米娜和卡迪·B。但她听音乐的时间足够长，足以理解并内化他会有多不赞成。
So you felt like there were things that you liked that you couldn't tell him about?
所以你觉得有些你喜欢的东西你不能告诉他？
No. Well, there were things that I liked that I could tell him about, but that I didn't feel like there was any point to telling him about because he would tell me all the errors. And I would be like, yo, like, listen to this person's voice! Or like, this song is so good, and play it. And then afterward, Papa would be like, you want to hear something good? And then run into where he keeps his records, and I'm like, oh gosh.
不。嗯，有些我喜欢的东西我可以告诉他，但我觉得没必要告诉他，因为他会告诉我所有的错误。我会说，哟，就像，听听这个人的声音！或者就像，这首歌太棒了，播放它。然后之后，爸爸会说，你想听点好东西吗？然后跑进他放唱片的地方，我就想，噢天哪。
Do you remember any examples of this?
你还记得这方面的例子吗？
One time, I was playing him a song from Hamilton, where someone was rapping really fast. And I played it, and he just, like, half listened. And then afterward, he's like, you want to hear really fast rapping? And I'm like, oh god.
有一次，我给他放了一首《汉密尔顿》里的歌，里面有人说唱得非常快。我播放了，他只是半听着。然后之后，他说，你想听听真正快的说唱吗？我想，噢天哪。
Well, what did you play her, Adam?
好吧，你给她放了什么，亚当？
Well, all right, all right. Let me back up for a second. Like--
好吧，好吧。让我先退一步。就像——
Sorry, Papa.
对不起，爸爸。
At the risk of getting on my soapbox and with the full understanding this is never going to make it actually into this piece. My thing with Hamilton was like, cool, Hamilton is fine. My issue with it is that a billion people who have no--
冒着站上讲台的风险，并充分理解这段话永远不会真正进入这篇作品。我对《汉密尔顿》的感觉是，酷，《汉密尔顿》还可以。我的问题是，十亿个没有……的人
Here, Adam's critique of Hamilton, while spirited, is mostly remarkable in that he somehow manages to vehemently object to the musical's popularity, while simultaneously name dropping his friendship with one of its former stars, Daveed Diggs. Vivian didn't just want to feel free to listen to Hamilton in the car on the way to school. She wanted to incorporate all of her newfound influences into her own music.
在这里，亚当对《汉密尔顿》的批评，虽然很有精神，但最引人注目的在于他不知何故成功地强烈反对这部音乐剧的流行，同时又提到了他与前明星之一戴维德·迪格斯的友谊。维维安不仅想在去学校的路上自由地在车里听《汉密尔顿》。她想把她所有新发现的影响力融入她自己的音乐中。
I felt like, I mean, it's really cool that I'm doing all Papa's cool stuff, but if I have this voice and I have access to this recording, can't I use it to do things that are more my style?
我觉得，我的意思是，我正在做所有爸爸觉得酷的东西真的很酷，但如果我有这个声音，我有这个录音通道，难道我不能用它做更符合我风格的事情吗？
It's not all that surprising that someone Vivian's age would eventually diverge from the path her father set her on when she was six. And this wasn't even the first time Vivian had stood up to her dad. She's usually pretty outspoken. But she told me this time was different-- that she had been more scared than usual to speak her mind, and that it took her months to work up the courage.
像维维安这个年纪的人最终会偏离她父亲六岁时为她设定的道路，这并不令人惊讶。这甚至不是维维安第一次反抗她爸爸。她通常很直言不讳。但她告诉我这次不一样——她比平时更害怕说出自己的想法，而且她花了几个月的时间才鼓起勇气。
She was right to be concerned. Adam took it noticeably hard. To hear him tell it, he interpreted this slight rejection as a sort of referendum on his parenting.
她的担心是对的。亚当受到的打击很明显。听他叙述，他把这种轻微的拒绝解读为对他育儿的一种公投。
I felt a certain kind of sadness on a couple of levels. First, disappointment in myself for getting carried away, and making her feel uncomfortable or making her feel like an unwilling participant in this project.
我感到一种某种程度上的悲伤。首先，对我自己感到失望，因为我太得意忘形，让她感到不舒服或感到自己是这个项目的非自愿参与者。
And also just a sense of letdown, that like wow, maybe we were no longer going to be hanging out after dinner, playing instrumentals and fitting rhymes to them, and practicing, and rehearsing, and cutting scratch demos, and that kind of thing. Because it was something that brought me a lot of joy, both reveling in her skill, but really, more than anything, just spending time together and that feeling of collaboration, which is wonderful when you find it with anybody. But when you find it with your own kid, it's magical.
还有一种被冷落的感觉，就像哇，也许我们再也不会在晚饭后闲逛，播放伴奏，填词，练习，排练，录制草稿小样之类的了。因为它带给我很多快乐，既沉浸在她的天赋中，但说实话，最重要的是，只是共度时光和那种协作的感觉，这在你发现它时是美妙的，无论和谁在一起。但当你和你自己的孩子发现这一点时，那是神奇的。
I mean, this is me, like, armchair psychotherapist, but was there any part of you that was deflecting some energy into this in a way that maybe was more for you than for Vivian?
我的意思是，我是那种沙发心理治疗师，但你有没有想过，你是不是在以某种方式把一些能量倾注到这个项目中，也许这更多是为了你而不是为了维维安？
That's a great question. I mean, the whole period of time that we're talking about is fairly tumultuous. I mean, from when Viv was six until now--
这是一个好问题。我的意思是，我们谈论的整个时间段都相当动荡。我的意思是，从维芙六岁到现在——
Five years.
五年。
Five years. I mean, that's a period of time that covers her mom and I splitting up. It covers a new relationship, two new babies. So yeah, you probably have a point there, I mean, at least in the sense of this being something that was purely fun, and exciting, and didn't feel heavy in any way.
五年。我的意思是，那是一段涵盖了她父母分居的时间。它涵盖了一段新恋情，两个新婴儿。所以是的，你可能说得对，我的意思是，至少就这是一种纯粹有趣、令人兴奋且没有任何沉重感的事情而言。
They never did finish that song. Adam and Vivian's magical collaboration was not infinitely sustainable. But so what?
他们最终没有完成那首歌。亚当和维维安的神奇合作并非无限可持续的。但那又怎样？
When everything was happening in our family also, it was a way for me to connect with Papa. And also after we'd had a lot of fun kicking rhymes, we could talk about the more important stuff. He could be like, how do you feel about the new baby? And I feel like it just-- I would be a lot less close with Papa now if we hadn't spent so much time together doing that. Like, I wouldn't be coming into your room and be like, let's talk about this.
当我们家里发生一切事情时，这是我与爸爸建立联系的一种方式。而且在我们玩得很开心之后，我们可以谈论更重要的事情。他可以说，你对新婴儿感觉如何？我觉得它只是——如果不是我们花那么多时间在一起做那件事，我现在会和爸爸亲近得多。就像，我不会走进你的房间说，我们谈谈这个吧。
Mm. But the rapping was a way into it.
嗯。但这说唱是切入点。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm glad. That makes me happy. I'm glad to hear that.
我很高兴。这让我很开心。很高兴听到这个。
Recently, Vivian has been getting more into singing. She writes her own poems and adapts them into songs. She's written a few, and she thinks she could be good at it with a little time and a little help.
最近，维维安对唱歌越来越感兴趣。她写自己的诗并把它们改编成歌曲。她写了几首，她认为只要有一点时间和一点帮助，她就能做得很好。
I wouldn't say that I totally want Papa to be out of my career as a singer. Like, he's super supportive, and he's obviously the one with all the connections. But--
我不会说我完全希望爸爸离开我的歌手事业。就像，他非常支持，而且他显然是那个拥有所有关系的人。但——
Practical. That's very practical of you. That's smart.
务实。你非常务实。这很聪明。
Yeah, it's very cold-blooded right there.
是的，这非常冷血。
I'm a father myself. It's a new thing-- so new, in fact, that all I can say definitively about the experience so far is that I am terrified every single day about what's coming. I look around to my friends as scared people do.
我自己也是个父亲。这是一件新鲜事——事实上太新了，以至于我目前能明确说的关于这种经历的唯一事情就是我每天都对即将发生的事情感到恐惧。我像害怕的人一样环顾四周我的朋友们。
And the thing that Adam pulled off gives me some hope. He found an easy way to be with his daughter through difficult times. He constructed something fun that they could share no matter what else was swirling around them. And the outcome was perhaps the best one that any parent can imagine. Vivian got it. At least for a little while, she was right there with him.
而亚当成功做到的事情给了我一些希望。他找到了一种在困难时期与女儿相处轻松的方式。他构建了一些有趣的东西，无论周围还有什么漩涡，他们都可以分享。而结果可能是任何父母所能想象的最好的结果。维维安懂了。至少有一段时间，她和他就在一起。
What do you guys remember? Do you guys remember-- does anyone remember the super complicated song?
你们记得什么吗？你们记得——有人记得那首超级复杂的歌吗？
Yeah.
是的。
[LAUGHS] [INAUDIBLE]
（笑）（听不清）
I remember only the second verse, though.
不过我只记得第二段。
Oh, do it.
噢，来一段。
Wait. Let me just do it in my head for a second. OK. You want me to do it now, Papi?
等等。让我在脑子里过一遍。好的。你想让我现在来吗，爸爸？
Yeah, do it.
是的，来吧。
(RAPPING) [INAUDIBLE] solemnly swear to scar you horribly. Destiny calling me, honestly [INAUDIBLE] me. But they can't do much harm to me. I'm open like a pharmacy. Karmically, I'm untouchable, highly combustible. Ah, I can't remember the rest right now.
（说唱）（听不清）庄严发誓要给你造成可怕的创伤。命运在呼唤我，诚实地（听不清）我。但他们对我造成不了多大伤害。我像药房一样开放。从因果报应上说，我是不可触碰的，高度易燃的。啊，我现在记不起剩下的了。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
The Jazz Wolf is back. What.
“爵士狼”回来了。什么。
Stop.
停。
Neil Drumming.
尼尔·德鲁明。
[MUSIC - BAHAMADIA, "WORDPLAY"]
（音乐 - 巴哈马迪亚，《WORDPLAY》）
Act Three, Where It Came From. OK, so our show today is about words that have special weight of one sort or another, especially when we're kids. And we thought we would end today's show with this, from one of our producers, Ben Calhoun.
第三幕，它来自哪里。好的，所以我们今天的节目是关于有某种重量的文字，特别是在我们还是孩子的时候。我们想以这个故事结束今天的节目，来自我们的制作人之一，本·卡尔霍恩。
This is a story that, honestly, I never imagined I'd tell on the radio. It happened when I was seven and my sister was two. We were grocery shopping with my mom in my hometown, Milwaukee. This is at Sentry Foods at 71st and Lisbon.
这是一个说实话，我从没想过会在广播里讲的故事。这件事发生在我七岁，我妹妹两岁时。我们和妈妈在我的家乡密尔沃基逛超市。是在第71街和里斯本的Sentry食品超市。
While we were in the store, my sister did the very normal toddler thing of deciding that she was tired and demanding to be carried. She started throwing a fit, whining, refusing to walk. My mom tried, but then did the normal parent thing of deciding to ignore the tantrum, just to shop as fast as she could and get the heck out of there.
我们在店里时，我妹妹做了非常正常的蹒跚学步的孩子会做的事，决定她累了并要求被抱。她开始发脾气、呜咽、拒绝走路。我妈妈试过了，但后来做了正常的家长会做的事——决定无视那场脾气，只是尽快购物并赶紧离开那里。
We were almost out of the store when all of a sudden, a man walked up to my sister. He stood right over her and shouted down at her, "Stop it. You stop it right now." He stomped his foot at her to scare her. "You stop it. Stop it right now."
我们快出店门时，突然，一个男人走到我妹妹身边。他站在她上方，对她大喊：“停下。你现在立刻停下。”他对着她跺脚来吓唬她。“你停下。现在就停下。”
I remember my sister staring at him, terrified. My mom stepped in to gather my sister up. "She's two, and she's having a tantrum," she said to the man. "You're too old to be having a tantrum."
我记得我妹妹盯着他，吓坏了。我妈介入把我妹妹抱了起来。“她才两岁，在闹脾气，”她对那个人说。“你太大了，不应该在这闹脾气。”
But the guy followed us, walking right behind us as we got into the parking lot, trying to get to our car. I remember it was hot and sunny, and otherwise, a beautiful day. For a second, it wasn't clear what the man was going to do. But then as he got closer, he started shouting a bunch of things at my mother. The one I remember specifically, "You people need to discipline your children."
但那家伙跟着我们，就在我们进入停车场试图走到车前时紧跟在我们身后。我记得那天很热，阳光明媚，否则是个美好的一天。有一秒钟，不清楚那个人要做什么。但当他靠近时，他开始对我母亲大喊大叫。我特别记得的那句是：“你们这些人需要管教好你们的孩子。”
My mom is Chinese-American. My family's mixed. Before we could get in our car, the man came right up to my mom and got in her face, puffing his chest out. He kept shouting. "You people need to go back where you came from!" he yelled. "Go back where you came from." That's how my mom and I both remember it.
我妈是美籍华人。我们家是混合家庭。在我们上车之前，那家伙走到我妈面前，贴近她的脸，挺起胸膛。他一直喊着。“你们这些人需要回到你们来的地方去！”他大喊。“回到你们来的地方去。”这就是我和我妈都记得的样子。
As he was yelling and in her face, I remember how my mom kind of froze. And I remember feeling very, very scared. This man was so much bigger than my mom, who's small-- just 5'2". And this guy was kind of a ruddy, older white man, who, if I had to bet, was maybe 60. For a second, I thought he might hit her or push her. And I felt that kid feeling of seeing something happening in the world of grown ups that you have absolutely no power over.
当他在大喊大叫并贴近她脸庞时，我记得我妈有点僵住了。我记得我感到非常、非常害怕。那个人比我妈大得多，她很小——只有5英尺2英寸。这家伙是个脸色红润、上了年纪的白人，如果我敢打赌，可能有60岁。有一秒钟，我以为他可能会打她或推她。我感觉到了那种作为孩子看到大人的世界里正在发生某些你完全无法控制的事情的感觉。
My mom, she had this panicked look on her face as she tried to find a way out. And that made me even more scared. I also remember feeling, for the first time ever, that my mom was in danger, not the normal kid feeling that your parents are kind of an unshakable raft of security.
我妈，她脸上带着惊恐的表情，试图寻找出路。那让我更害怕了。我还记得我第一次感觉到，我妈处于危险之中，而不是那种正常的孩子感觉，觉得父母是某种不可动摇的安全筏。
I told my son this story last week. He's seven, the same age I was when this happened. And when I told him, the fear we felt was the thing I left out-- how menacing it was, how scared we were.
上周我把这个故事讲给了我儿子听。他七岁，和我当时发生这件事时一样大。当我告诉他时，我漏掉了我们感到的恐惧——那是多么具有威胁性，我们当时有多害怕。
I'm not sure how long this moment in the parking lot went before a young guy, who worked at the store, who'd been in the parking lot gathering carts, was suddenly nearby. He was smaller than the guy and built like a teenager, but he said loudly to the guy, "Leave her alone." And then it was just kind of over.
我不确定在停车场这个时刻持续了多久，直到一个在店里工作的年轻小伙子，一直在这个停车场收集购物车，突然就在附近。他比那个家伙小，长得像个少年，但他大声对那个家伙说，“别找她麻烦。”然后事情就那样结束了。
This was the first time I realized that someone could do this, that my mother's right to belong was somehow different. That because she looks the way she looks, and I look the way I look, it was an invisible trap door always under us-- a question about whether we belonged as much as others, which itself was a statement that we hadn't totally belonged in the first place.
这是我第一次意识到有人能这样做，意识到我母亲拥有的归属权不知何故是不同的。因为她长得那样，我也长得那样，这就像我们脚下总有一个隐形的活板门——一个关于我们是否像其他人一样有归属权的问题，这本身就是一个声明，我们本来就没有完全归属过。
This has never been a story I've told all that much. Like, I never thought it was something that would have any kind of contemporary resonance, in part because I considered it a remnant of something on the wane. That the sentiment of that man, even if it was out there, it was shrinking toward some horizon.
这个故事我并没有讲过太多。就像，我从来没觉得它会产生任何当代共鸣，部分原因是我认为它是某种正在衰退的事物的残余。那个人的情绪，即使它存在，也在向地平线收缩。
For that matter, I never thought the meaning of this story would feel complicated. If anything, it was pat. It was the stuff of after school specials and teachers saying the country wasn't a melting pot, it was a stew pot. It was fine for those things, but not very interesting otherwise. And I never thought I'd be wrong about that until now.
就此而言，我从未想过这个故事的意义会感觉复杂。如果有的话，它是陈词滥调。那是课后专题和老师们说的那些国家不是大熔炉，而是炖肉锅的素材。那些东西可以，但除此之外并不太有趣。我从未想过我在这方面会错，直到现在。
Now for obvious reasons, I've been thinking about this a lot, in part because those congresswomen don't look unlike my mom did when she was in her 30s, and the guy did not look unlike the president. I never once thought, in the last 30 whatever years, that this story would ever be a political one. I'm surprised that it is. And I'm surprised how it is. I never once thought that people might hear this and put me on one side or the other of anything. I never would have thought that was even possible.
现在，由于显而易见的原因，我一直在思考这个问题，部分原因是那些女国会议员长得并不像我妈30多岁时的样子，而那个男的长得并不像总统。过去30多年里，我从来没想过这个故事会成为一个政治故事。我惊讶于它竟然是。而且我惊讶于它是如何成为这样的。我从来没想过人们可能会听到这个，并把我归为任何一方。我从未想过那甚至是有可能的。
But aside from the big things I didn't anticipate, I want to leave you with what might be the smallest. When I decided to tell this story, I called my mom to check my memory. When we talked, all the details were where I thought they were. Everything matched.
但除了那些我没预料到的大事之外，我想留给你可能最小的一件。当我决定讲述这个故事时，我给妈妈打电话核实我的记忆。我们谈话时，所有细节都在我以为它们在的地方。一切都对上了。
But she also told me something I didn't know. See, that grocery store, the Sentry store at the corner of 71st and Lisbon, it's still her grocery store. She's been shopping there for years.
但她也告诉我一些我不知道的事。瞧，那家超市，位于71街和里斯本转角的Sentry超市，那依然是她的超市。她已经在那里购物多年了。
But she told me, maybe five years ago, before any of these big national developments, that she went in one day and she asked to talk to the owner. She did that because she wanted to tell him this story decades after it happened. Because whoever that clerk was, he'd seen what that man was doing, and he'd stepped in. She didn't know who he was or think the owner would know, but she wanted someone to know how grateful she still is. I am, too.
但她告诉我，大约五年前，在所有这些重大的国家发展之前，她有一天进去要求和老板谈谈。她那样做是因为她想在事情发生几十年后讲这个故事。因为那个店员是谁，他看到了那个男人在做什么，并且介入了。她不知道他是谁，也没想过老板会知道，但她想让某人知道她依然是多么感激。我也是。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - EDITH FROST, "IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE WORDS"]
（音乐 - 伊迪丝·弗罗斯特，《IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE WORDS》）
Our program was produced today by Sean Cole and Bim Adewunmi with help from Nadia Reiman. The people who put this show together today include Elna Baker, Emanuele Berry, Ben Calhoun, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Whitney Dangerfield, Neil Drumming, Damien Grave, Jessica Lussenhop, Stowe Nelson, Catherine Raimondo, Ben Phelan, Tracy [INAUDIBLE], Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Svetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由肖恩·科尔和比姆·阿德温米制作，纳迪亚·雷曼协助。今天制作这个节目的团队包括埃尔娜·贝克、伊曼纽尔·贝里、本·卡尔霍恩、佐伊·蔡斯、达纳·奇维斯、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、尼尔·德鲁明、达米安·格雷夫、杰西卡·卢森霍普、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、本·费伦、特蕾西（听不清）、阿丽莎·希普、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。我们的总编辑是黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。
Special thanks to David Judy Meltzer, Bishop Gene Robinson, Dr. Barry Holtz, Deborah Moore, Hamza Syed, Ahmed Ali Akbar, Zainab Shah, Khalid Latif, Hannah Jewell, Ben Zimmer, Karl Baker, and Tom Howell.
特别感谢戴维·朱迪·梅尔策、吉恩·罗宾逊主教、巴里·霍尔茨博士、黛博拉·摩尔、哈姆扎·赛义德、艾哈迈德·阿里·阿克巴、扎伊纳布·沙赫、哈立德·拉蒂夫、汉娜·朱厄尔、本·齐默、卡尔·贝克和汤姆·豪威尔。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 675 episodes, news, videos, and lists of favorites, and tons of other stuff there. Or get our app, which has all that stuff and also lets you download as many episodes as you want. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以流媒体播放我们超过675集的档案、新闻、视频和最爱列表，以及海量的其他内容。或者下载我们的应用程序，它拥有所有那些东西，并且还可以让你下载你想下载的尽可能多的剧集。再次声明，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换台）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He just saw the film Cool Runnings last week, and he wondered, is that a documentary?
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他上周刚看了电影《冰上轻舞》，他想知道，那是纪录片吗？
Really, the first thing I did was send it to every Jamaican I knew. And be like, yo, so what do you think about this?
真的，我做的第一件事就是把它发给我认识的每一个牙买加人。心想，哟，所以你们觉得这个怎么样？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - EDITH FROST, "IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE WORDS"]
（音乐 - 伊迪丝·弗罗斯特，《IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE WORDS》）